你敢相信這個AI的架站工具竟然猛成這個樣子
不用寫程式
不用學設計
不用找團隊 只要動動你的小手指
整個網站用AI通通幫你搞定
這不是建站工具了
他根本是一個你家的免費設計總監加上文案高手加上技術外包的工程師
還在苦惱做網站的朋友
這一集我們給他看下去
嗨各位又是我AJ
很多人有過這個想法 就是我想要做一個自己的網站
讓大家能夠認識我
但現實是什麽呢
現實你要選平台
搞設計寫文案 弄半天還不知道網站從哪邊開始
別害怕 今天這集我們來帶來一個超猛的AI工具
讓你輕松跳過這些障礙
那到底是什麽神器能夠讓這些完全不會設計
也不懂程式的人能夠做出像設計師操刀一樣的網站呢
答案就是Hostinger website builder
以前做網站 選平台
弄排版寫文案還要為自己學點技術 搞到人神共憤
許多人連首頁還沒有架好就先投降了
但現在呢
你只要回答幾個簡單的問題
AI就會自動幫你生出整個網站
包含內容
排版圖片
風格 一條龍通通幫你生
不僅又快而且穩
而且漂亮
還能夠自己修改樣式
根本不需要技術背景
更扯的是呢
他還幫你配了一整套AI工具組
包含LOGO自動產生
圖片即時生成
AI文案生成
還有SEO的AI調整
從頭到尾直接開外掛讓你爽爽的建立一個網站
真的完全沒跟你開玩笑
然後來了來了
注意 超級喜訊
我們泛科學院的觀眾有專屬的合作優惠
Hostinger直接開後門給我們一組VIP等級的折扣碼2025panchool
只要你從下方的這個專屬連結點進去
不僅全功能會開放
還會打9折的優惠
這個就只有我們的頻道觀眾能用啦
其他人要用還沒有門呢
不記得沒有關系 現在記得按讚訂閱開啟小鈴鐺
我們的頻道資訊欄里面通通都有連結
想要回來看的時候隨時都可以點
那大家一定會好奇方案要怎麽選呢
我已經幫你1秒拆解啦
第一個叫做Premium website builder
適合要做形象官網或者是個人網站品牌作品級的你
只要每個月2.99塊美金就可以擁有25個網站空間
150種模板
還送一年的免費網域
全套的AI工具直接全部送給你
從LOGO到SEO通通升好升滿
CP值直接炸裂
第二個business website builder
這個適合做電商網站開設線上課程 或者是你要有會員系統
或者是你要做線上收款
只要一個月3.99塊美金就可以讓你做50個網站資源
100種支付方式
最狂的是交易手續費0趴
沒錯 零趴
從建站到接單到收錢一站包辦
一鍵賺錢
重點是呢
因為我們的折扣碼2025panschool還可以再打9折
哇這價錢根本就不是入門是倒貼好嗎 等著你來創業了
好介紹完了你應該迫不及待想要試試看吧
那我們來實際上期實測一下帶你直接看Hostinger 到底有多扯let's go
那我們就直接通過我們這個頻道下方這個連結
那你就可以來到Hostinger這個網站
那你就直接右上角點選login
然後你就可以用你的gmail賬號
或者是Facebook賬號來去登錄
點選Google
好 這最簡單
這樣就賬號就完成申請了 非常輕松簡單
他這邊會有包含網站的設定然後域名
然後信箱 VPS 監控暗網 賬單 市場
好那我們就直接來試著建立一個網站
所以 我們來添加一個網站
那這個網站里面 他就會有Hostinger的那個horizon
用AI創建網路應用程序工具
然後wordpress你也可以自己建購你自己的wordpress網站
或者是你可以用Hostinger建站助手
或者是你是高手你可以直接建一個空白的PHP的網站
或者是你可以從外面把你的網站搬進來
好那我們這邊就選用AI驅動的這個托放式件站助手
假設各位都是麻瓜 簡單一點的就是用這個AI建站助手
那進來之後 就取一個品牌名稱 比如說
泛科學院線上課程讀書會 這個地方 你只要簡單的描述一下
比如說
建構一個泛科學院線上課程的讀書會網站
好的 當然他因為可以存很多東西
所以你可以直接把你的需求把它寫上去
好然後 我們就直接create a website
泛科學院線上課程讀書會 共同學習探索知識的海洋
讀書會是互動學習平台共同成長社群
幫你配上了圖片 讀書會有哪些服務 可以答案分享 活動發布
然後讀書會平台 聯絡我們
然後下面的footer都幫你做好了
收集你的Email
那這邊可以改配色 比如說改成橘色的
然後沒有問題 你還可以看一下手機版本的
而且還是還是給你動態的背景
我覺得這真的是做的還不錯
所以他這邊有課程專區有讀書會有個人中心
真的還是假的
如果你不滿意啊你可以creat again 然後再重新的去調整你的這個提示語
讓他去生成一些元件
頁面 功能
你可以用簡單的幾句話就把網站的東西交代進去
不過當然他既然都給你到700個字那麽多 那當然你要發揮你的聰明才智
把你的所思所想 你的那些明確的需求都把它寫進去
寫的越詳細
那他在生成的時候就會命中率就會越高
然後這邊還有這個version history就是你可以用那個不同的版本生成
然後去調整你那個舊版的這個生成結果跟內容
好所以我們這邊我們再做一個新的好了
suggestion add online store in my site哦
所以你的需求里面他分析要是需要新增購物車這個功能
他也會自動幫你把這個購物車的功能加進去 我覺得這還不錯試試看
好creat website
線上課程讀書會網站
這次改成了
賺點數
可以解鎖課程
好然後course的好 課程的那個
分類 就是課程的列表
免費的課程
你可以買越多啊送越多啊哎還有這個
這個陌生人啊給我們的五星評價
看起來還不錯哦
好看一下version history 這是第二版本那如果你不滿意你可以回到第一版本
version history我覺得還不錯 就是你在這麽多AI生成的網站里面
其實我覺得最常遇到的一個狀況就是他一直生成
然後結果你突然間覺得說
昨天生的那個版本我比較喜歡
那這個他就是有把這些東西做出來就還不錯
他會留下那個最後的五個版本
好那所以如果你第一版你就不要
你可以讓他再做第二版
第三版 第四版 第五版
然後你就可以再去不同版本里面挑選你喜歡的這些原件把它弄過來好
那我們留下用第一個版本好了
然後配色不改的
這個不管他
這樣子你就獲得了一個網站的一個結構 這個草稿了
那當然你就需要去調整一下真實
你的聯絡資訊 Email
好了之後呢
你可以去connect domain
他現在專業版會免費送你一年份的這個網域 那如果你沒有綁定的話呢
你可以先用一些臨時性網域 我們在做測試嘛
所以就是這樣子沒問題
然後客成專區就是另外一個頁面
然後讀書會跟課程專區同一個頁面所以首頁是首頁
然後個人中心這是第三個頁面
所以一次生成就直接幫你生成的首頁
課程專區還有讀書會
然後如果沒有什麽問題的話基本上你到現在就可以直接發布網站
一秒鐘完成上線然後就可以直接view site
做好了
是不是超級快啊
但是哦
可能還有很多東西還沒有做好 所以呢我們回到剛剛的這個編輯畫面
左邊這邊呢
有一個叫做AI tools的選單
這個AI tools里面它整合了各種各式各樣的比如說AI圖片生成
AI文字生成 AI頁面生成 AI段落生成 AI部落格生成
AI產品細節描述的生成
AI SEO的助理
還有AI的logo生成 接下來
我們來到了這個線上讀書會 那你讓我這張圖不滿意
那我就可以直接
生成圖像
然後就是可以講說
有一群人正在電腦前學習使用chatgpt
而且大家的臉上都充滿笑容
旁邊的老師也非常親切的協助大家解決課程電腦的
操作問題
好的create
給了我兩張
這一張 還是這一張呢
感覺都
還行 這張可能好一點
好然後 接下來我來想要新增一個section
這個section generator
那這個要做什麽呢
新增泛科學的介紹頁面
特別介紹鄭國威知識長
掛名推薦
沒有掛名
隨便寫寫啊
然後泛科學是台灣最大線上垂直
科普
新聞網站等等等 好就這樣送出
還不錯哦 有科學的感覺
有數字
那這個答案你都要去做一些調整
然後知識長貢獻啊 然後了解然後就可以去點做更多的頁面出來
這樣子輕松做了一個新的section出來
我覺得這個結果還OK
符合我期待啊
那接下來我要去做泛科學的介紹
那我就要去寫一個比如說布羅格生成器
然後正式300-500字
那我們就可以去泛科學
網站 然後維基百科好了
那我們就可以把它
輕松的覆制起來
然後輕松的貼回來
生成
運作模式未來的展望哇
非常的好
部落格在這裏探索泛科學
所以 我們就需要去
比如說我把這一篇把它
unpublish變draft
這是draft
可以把它給它
publish哦
這樣子我們回到我們的首頁
泛科學的這個部落格文章就這樣生成了
所以我覺得這一塊的這個部落格文章生成器這也做的還蠻好的
就是你可以直接把你的需求寫進去之後呢
他就可以直接幫你生成一份草稿
然後他就排版都做的還OK啊
然後會自動配上一張圖片那當然這圖片你可能還是需要做一些調整啊
根據你自己的需求
或者是你可以直接換掉 就是上傳你自己的圖檔
然後來去生成
當然你也可以AI去生成內容 你可以去網絡上找一些
開源的這些圖片
這個部落格的這個文章的這個封面配圖啊
我覺得這到這邊這個section Generator段落的這個生成我覺得還蠻不錯的好
然後部落格文章生成我覺得這也很棒
好然後再來是product detail Generator
實體商品
多樣實體商品
虛擬商品當然要虛擬商品
然後我們來AI斜杠新手村
我直接給他一個商品圖
讓他來
生成看看究竟會做成什麽樣子 我也很好奇好送出
直接分析圖片
adventure with AI
start your journey with the strongest NPC best seller
哇可惜的是現在還不支援中文的文字生成
把以下內容
改成繁體中文三個雙引號 貼上原本的文字 三個雙引號
還行 然後 這邊就沒法改了
這個就是也自己手動去調一下這個中文的描述
這邊看起來也還行
然後數量 價錢
100塊
折價 SKU
哇這也是有那個庫存管理的概念
然後你可以
好所以你可以直接上傳下單購買之後你可以給他他能夠獲得的檔案
或者是他能夠獲得的共用連結
就可以在線上直接輕松銷售電子商品
比如說電子筆記 這種東西就是在這種時候你可以直接發這個地方哦
你可以加什麽呢
哦加一些額外的描述
他還可以AI建議哦AI guide
OK
save
好好的我的斜槓新手村就順利的上架了
好接下來呢
你可以去update your company information你可以把你的那個商店的名稱去做更新
然後review and the setup you are shipping你可以去調整他的那個
送貨的一些設定
然後你可以設定
付款的方式我們來看看
然後你可以連接你的paypal 好那我這邊先不動它
然後你的公司的LOGO
公司的名稱
公司的聯絡方式 這個也不動他
收據 你可以自定然後把logo換掉哦這個應該也沒什麽問題
然後我們先存起來
好再來我們來看一下他的SEO的設定
AI SEO assistant
Generator new SEO info你可以根據你的
頁面的內容哦給他一些簡單的描述他去重新幫你寫Google的SEO的結果
我們現在調首頁好了
這個好
然後按next三個keyword啊
讀書會泛科學院 課程 好
next set up
他這邊就會幫你把網站的名稱
SEO的title還有這個MatA的description幫你放上來
那你就可以依照你的調那個喜好去做一些調整
這個就是他直接在Google搜取的結果
里面你會看到了這一個網站的這個網址
那個網址我們還沒有做調整
所以他還是顯示暫時的這個預覽網址那如果你綁定了你自己的網域呢
那這邊應該就會出現一個很漂亮的你自己的網域
好了之後就按finish
後續的部分他會告訴你說
他說你這邊寫太少了啊
最好是寫到156個字
所以呢你可以針對別人可能會搜尋到你的這些關鍵字
還有你的這些
更進一步的描述
把這個地方做好
他會去給你一些相關的SEO建議
好那如果你有一些頁面你不想要被網絡上Google能夠搜尋到呢
你也可以點這個hide page from search result
那就會幫你把這個頁面從這個google搜尋的結果里面藏起來
那就會直接比較友善的啊
讓你去在google搜尋的時候容易進入你想要顧客進來的那些頁面
所以如果都沒有問題的話就直接關起來然後update website
這樣網站就完成更新
看一下我們的這個網站的首頁
網站的首頁 好編輯
update然後我們就直接去看網站本身
進到網站里面去之後 我們可以直接把網站截個圖下來
輕松的截個圖
那hostinger呢
在他的那個後台里面還有一個東西叫AI tool
AI tool里面有一個功能叫做注意力熱圖
以前我們要做這種注意力熱圖 這個東西是什麽
就是你可以把你的網站丟進去給AI 給這些注意力熱圖分析的網站
然後這種工具
他就會幫你分析出觀眾看到你的頁面的時候
他到底最容易一開始關注哪些地方
所以 假如我們的網站設計好之後
把這截圖放進去這個注意力熱圖哦現在都說AI在在在判斷了
所以我把網站的截圖放進去他就會告訴我說
觀眾其實會去看這個地方
還有這個地方跟這個地方好
所以你在這個地方觀眾喜歡看的這些位置你就要去特別
去優化去強調你的一些比如說優惠啦
或者是你的一些網站特色啦
所以你在網站做好之後你就可以通過這個注意力熱圖
以前你要去找一些付費服務啊
甚至是用一些專門的這些網站
甚至更早期你要用所謂的眼球追蹤啊
就是你要真的找一個人
然後就裝眼球追蹤的程式然後儀器
觀察他使用電腦的這個眼球的定位的狀況
然後他就去畫出你的這個網站的注意力熱圖啊
所以有了這個注意熱圖之後呢
現在開發網站真正的非常非常容易啊
你就可以直接這個上傳一張新圖片
然後你就可以去分析你的網站的內容里面
到底哪一些地方是觀眾特別會注意看的地方
你就要把你的那些優惠啦
或者是把你那些吸引觀眾的那些內容把它擺在觀眾會看的位置
好所以這個注意力這個圖現在用AI分析真的是太方便了
以前做到快死掉
所以這個就是他除了這個AI tool之外呢
他還有其他的一些各種各式各樣的這些產品比如說訓練主機啦
BPS 或者是那個域名注冊
域名轉換啦
或者是你可以去跟Google的這個email來去做一些域名的綁定哦等等
然後除了剛剛有試過的logo生成器之外
哦你也可以接上VPN
所以這些在市場啊它的這個類似APP store這個功能
我覺得這也是hostinger它里面做的還蠻有趣的一個地方
這邊快速幫大家整理一下hostinger這個建站工具的
它最大的優點就是 第一個超級簡單
真的只要回答幾個問題一下就能夠直接幫你搭好整個網站
不用自己從0開始慢慢堆
第二個功能超級齊全
因為從網站的排版
文案的撰寫
LOGO的設計
圖片的生產到SEO優化熱點分析
過去這些工具 沒錯都有一些現成的這些工具
要靠不同工具才能完成這些事情
這里這個網站他試圖一次通通幫你搞定
第三速度超級快
你不用等設計師改圖排版
寫文案幾分鐘之後你就可以結合AI快速設置一個完整度超高
可以直接上線的網站
超多時間更麻煩
第四個自由度超高
其實是AI幫你生成出來的版型你要自己改標題改版型
換圖片都超級直覺拖拉點選就可以搞定
完全不需要技術背景
能夠做出超有質感的網站
另外這邊其實也要講一下
其實市面上有其他類似AI工具可以做到其中的一些功能
比如說寫文案啦
生成圖片啦
那當然hostinger說實話了他做的也不一定比人家強
可是hostinger他真的厲害的地方就是把這些功能試試把它整合在一起
你不用在各個平台那邊湊來湊去好不用自己把這個拉來拉去好
版型那邊弄好之後把它搬來搬去
在hostinger的上面 一個流程一個東西直接一個section就直接生成就直接搞定了
好所以從建站 內容生成
版型設計
SEO優化到網站上線直接一體成型
直接讓你專心的做好你自己想要做的事情
讓現在變成一個輕松又快速的事情
所以說如果你想要快速擁有一個專業的網站
不想被各種繁瑣的流程拖磨
hostinger這個website view的真的是超級值得一試
在這個時代AI工具其實已經百花齊放
什麽寫文案吶
畫圖 做網站
種類真的多到選不完
但問題就是它到底哪一個才是最適合自己的AI工具
這才是真正重要的關鍵
以現在全球趨勢來看
一站式整合式的AI功就會開始慢慢的成為主流
因為大家懶惰 沒有人想要浪費時間在不同的平台直接來回跳來跳去
自己組裝流程麻煩而且浪費時間呢
那今天帶大家看到這個hostinger website builder的就是一個很好的例子
他用最少的操作用最快的速度
讓你把網站架站所需要的所有的工具跟流程
從設計文案排版到EO優化通通打包搞定
如果你也想要走到前面
不只是想要用AI
而是用對的AI來幫自己省下更多的時間
提升自己的工作效率
我真的很推薦hostinger的這個網站
你可以來去試試看
詳細的資訊我都下放在影片下方的連結
有興趣的話可以點進去看看
也別忘了輸入我專屬的折扣碼
你可以拿到額外的優惠
今天的影片就到這邊
如果你喜歡這類的AI工具實測應用分享的話記得按讚訂閱
開啟小鈴鐺我們下期影片再見嘍拜拜